une jeux portés par les garçons comme
une revendication depuis quelques jours
des élèves dans différentes écoles
secondaires ont utilisé leurs uniformes
scolaires pour faire passer un message
la pression faite aux femmes notamment
quant à leur tenue vestimentaire doit
cesser quand même encore ce sujet les
jets qui fait partie de nos
conversations et des problèmes qui
surviennent
donc c'est sûr qu'il faut que ça change
c'est dans cet esprit que simon lefèvre
gagnon a approché la direction son école
avec son accord
il a partagé l'idée de porter la jupe à
ses collègues masculins
rapidement plus d'une cinquantaine de
garçons se sont jointes au mouvement
on veut pas abolir l'uniforme mais c'est
sûr qu'on veut qu ait du changement on
est une génération qui cherche
changement et c'est sûr que oui on veut
dénoncer la pression qu'on met sur les
femmes au collège saint paul de varennes
l'invitation a été lancée par un petit
groupe d'élèves via les réseaux sociaux
en tant qu' on se doit de soutenir soit
pas cessé d excuse la société je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui dans la société dans
laquelle on ne devrait pas vous le but
du message était surtout de dire que si
on porte une jupe un peu plus courte ou
un peu plus longue c'est vraiment notre
choix c'est pas comment savait qu'il
veut déferré comment on est des photos
accompagnées de l'opinion des élèves ont
été publiés sur instagram
cinq jours plus tard la publication de
guillaume néry a récolté 80 milles
mention j'aime les commentaires et les
partages se comptent par dizaines
la preuve selon lui que la discussion
devait avoir lieu souvent la société
essaie de remettre
la responsabilité de ce qui leur arrive
sur eux s'ils disent si une fille s'est
fait mal parlé dans la rue baissé à
cause de ce qu'est porte le mouvement
fait boule de neige dans plusieurs
établissements de la région de montréal
d'abord surprise la direction du collège
jean eudes a elle aussi voulu emboîter
le pas on les range en 2020 pour prévoir
un assouplissement les moeurs évoluent
puis à travers tout ce nous on demeure
quand même toujours toujours dans
l'esprit des valeurs fondatrices de
notre collège qui sont des valeurs
d'ouverture de tolérance puis
d'accueillir nos jeunes le but ce
mouvement c'est pas que ça s'arrête à
une journée c'est que ça continue avec
pour objectif de lancer un dialogue mais
surtout de changer les choses ici qui me
remettrai au canada montréal